how did you become financially free in
five days bro so you did this with also
with no money no money down on top of
that i was also homeless
hey what's up my name's samuel lee's i
want to introduce you to a guy called
emmanuel and i helped emmanuel become
financially free and it took him
five days now you might think get out of
here that's unbelievable that's
unrealistic whatever so in this video
i'm going to interview emmanuel and he's
going to describe exactly step by step
what happened how we did it so that you
can do the same thing too so emmanuel
welcome to my house thanks so much for
coming down yes samuel thank you for
having me thank you for having me how
are you it's a financial freedom in five
years i'm blown away man i mean honestly
that's what you've done is incredible
but break it down
so
how did you become financially free in
five days bro in five days well i
started at your
your property crash course you know i
attended your free event
and i went to all of your events i said
all right cool long term development
short term i need cash flow right
rent to rent let's go so i signed up to
your course done the online course
attended your four days training you
know the rent to rent
hmo boot camp service accommodation
and then within five days she called my
first steal financially free what
secured two deals financially free
well i had four deals i sold two
goes from one to two to four so what
what hang on hang on so you did two
deals within a matter of days then you
got another two deals which you sold to
help pay for those deals yes so you did
this with also with no money no money
down bang bro bro bro all right so we're
going to need to break this down because
the guys on youtube
some of the guys on youtube will be
cheering you on right now some of them
will be going like congratulations yeah
and tune in and others will be going
yeah whatever being skeptical um so so
for the skeptics
what strategy to use and and and like to
explain what rent to rent is because
there's so many people on youtube and on
tick tock that say oh rent to rent is
illegal or rent to rent is a scam and
those people you know i haven't got clue
what they're talking about because
pretty much every hotel that you see is
a rent to rent yes
so if it's because because the hotel
doesn't own the building no they don't
and neither do i i don't under building
either is other hotels at scout is it
illegal no so talk me through what is
rent to rent talk through the strategy
and then we'll go through what you did
and then we'll learn about your story so
firstly what is rent to rent so renter
in is when i agree a deal with the
landlord which allows me to take the
property give the landlord a fixed
guaranteed rent for a fixed amount of
term so i've got it for three years
allows me i'll put it as a corporate
letter through my company which allows
me to rent it out room by room for a
super rent you know so i'll give the
landlord their portion bills and the
rest
that's my end okay that sounds great so
basically the the landlord is getting a
guaranteed flat no hassle peace of mind
you're then renting as a hmo the
landlord might not want to be a hmo
landlord he might think oh i can't be
bothered with multiple tenants and so so
he's getting a flat rent you're then
turning into a hmo you're keeping the
profit yeah so where are these deals
talk to me through your first deal how
did you find it and what the figures
literally done your course use your
strategy samuel so i literally
found my first deal on gumtree
went there bit skeptical grew to the
landlord
and literally just sorted it like that
so i used gumtree for that and for
tenants your strategy is all again from
the course i went on spare room
literally i had one lady come she took
four rooms
like that wow my first viewing literally
why does she need four rooms oh so
great news i'm working with a company
now to help them house their staff so
they have staff so now i just agreed a
two three-year contract with them
they say we need a house in this area
perfect what so basically yes basically
you got a uh you found a landlord on
gumtree and you have to be pretty
motivated yeah your house and gumtree
right yes or all not really what you're
doing because most people all about the
house that would probably go down a more
traditional route so this guy stuck it
on gumtree yeah because he didn't want
no estate agents he said are you agency
i said no it'll be a corporate letter
where i'll be managing it and looking
after it for you and he just said
brilliant come take a look went there
everything's brand new fully furnished
new beds wardrobes etc needed a bit of
work where is it uh north london in
edmonton in edmonton yes okay so how
much rent are you paying the landlord so
i've agreed from 3200 i negotiated it
down all the way to 2 400 pounds nice
yeah my guy
so two thousand four hundred why did he
drop the rent so much because i said
samuel how come you don't do it yourself
i wanna spend time with the wife the
kids see the grandkids on the traffic on
holiday i said perfect samuel
i'm gonna go back crunch some numbers
and i'll get back to you tomorrow bang
so basically you followed by the letter
yes what we do on the training yes
hundred percent you go on gumtree yes
call landlords and someone did you get
did you get any no did you get no's
before you got a yes i had 70 knows
70 calls volume volume volume
no no no no that's illegal oh nice
multi-let now i don't want to hear about
corporate but here's the thing is really
interesting is you achieved a lot in
five days right which is increase which
is crazy but you had to go through
70 rejections first most people wouldn't
be prepared to put themselves through
that but 70 rejections 17 being told no
70 times only takes about 70 minutes
you're calling up an animal and going hi
yeah my name's emmanuel you know are you
open to corporate letters i've got a
company it's probably available and
they're just like oh no
that might be a minute call yeah so 70
calls like that you're actually only on
the phone for an hour and 10 minutes
bruh like an hour and 10 minutes
but most people wouldn't put themselves
through that rejection for that time you
did
now you're reaping the rewards you did
what most people aren't prepared to do
you invested yes
a couple thousand pounds yes going on my
training program
most people wouldn't do that you took 70
rejections most people wouldn't do that
because you did what most people won't
do
now you're getting the results most
people could never get yes correct you
know so all right so you rent it for two
four yeah and then and then and then
what what do you do so he agrees what's
the next step i said
i need to see proof you actually own the
property hmo license get all the bills
council tax etc everything comes let's
call it 350. yeah
call
and then the rest is all my profit so
for my first deal
i'm making 1250 60 pounds from my very
first deal no wonder you're so gassed
and you and your tenant you've got a
fixed contract
with them tenants are secured till and
then i've gone back to renegotiate the
length of it
because i have the company supplying me
the stuff anyway what's like your reason
for doing this because you're clearly
hungry brother like you came to the
program i could see your hunger you were
there like really bang out the course
like what's what's your what's your
strongest reason for doing this i would
say my strongest reason it started with
athletics you know i you know 2012 i was
running for great britain you know
competing when the team gb kit you know
and
through that period all the way till you
know last year covid you know i was
being successful i was running for
england you know at the olympic stadium
in stratford thinking yes you know i'm
achieving and then
i got injured i had a big injury you
know you know when you get injured you
feel like your dreams are shattered you
know can't walk toward this muscle tall
my knee
tendons struggling bed bound for three
four months feeling very depressed and
you know funding there's no funding
you're injured you're hurt you're down
and out and it just feels like
everything's come to an end you know you
just think what am i going to do with
myself you know you're putting on weight
you're not training you're not eating
you know and on top of that i was also
homeless you know and a lot of people
don't know that you know so i've
literally gone from representing the
country to rock bottom
no and i said i'm gonna try one more
time with the injuries and the injuries
and then
i just thought nah i need to be better
than this i can be better than this so
step by step learn how to walk and not a
jog
okay how can i build wealth how can i
help retire my family help my mom you
know how can i help that homeless guy on
the street that i see you know i want to
leave a legacy you know i want to do
what you've done with charities you know
and have my own helping homeless people
on the streets you know things like that
so i had that burning desire and plus my
discipline from athletics you know
moved that over into property i you know
got comfortable being uncomfortable i
said okay i can only do what i can do
and i just gotta let god do the do the
rest you know and then i saw your book
you know do the possible you know watch
god do the impossible and literally like
i just kept going kept driving kept
achieving step by step and then property
invested go go go go some days i'm like
ah i'm like 15 hours sleep this week
okay i need to rest because i don't want
to burn out you know so i got a big
inspiration from you your energy
and literally i was able to you know
sort the property get two carpets fitted
for 250 pounds for two double rooms i
was able to get a new boiler in for 150
pounds including labor you know and of
course two google reviews as well you
know they love a review and not just
pilot so literally just your energy i
said yes samuel's the man i need to
learn from this guy attended all your
events you know attending your training
whilst in your training deal after deal
call after call call after call and
literally on the last day i even had to
leave early you know
when for viewing yeah i even had to
leave early so yeah i left and then a
couple days later you know i secured the
deal done i messaged you i remember say
samuel
remember this day 21st of october
winners on a wednesday i'm coming you
know and literally here i am i can see
now why you associated with property
because i think with you being a a
runner representing england
you to do that in in you know athletes
have to have serious discipline serious
that you know and to apply that over to
property yeah you know were you a
sprinter yeah 1200 meters
[Laughter]
i mean honestly we've had a it's been
it's been a roller coaster you know and
even like the landlord was just so
impressed that they like you know my
brother's banner a property he wants to
convey into all ensuite so i was like
yeah that'll be a great idea he's like
how much do you charge to manage
properties i said oh and i'm going to be
a property manager managing profit you
know all these opportunities and then i
also get to help people you know so now
i've got uh i don't want to say too much
in it but got to you know supported
living and if you know about support
living
you know and it would literally you know
take my income and multiply it by 10.
and at the same time helping people and
helping people which is the most
important thing so your first deal how
long did it take from you being on the
training and we spent four days together
yeah you know on the training yeah so so
did you find the gumtree elite at the
training did you find it after the
training at the training
on the day on the train i was on
zoopla right move open rent
gumtree and on the train and oh like
mate you pick up the phone and call
people you're you're doing stuff yeah
so so your first
not deal but the lead came at the
training yes and you booked to go view
it yes and then you went to see it and
the landlord was just like you know look
i'm looking to rent it out you know got
a really good rent yeah you then fixed
it up so that's making you 1200 pounds a
month profit yes
from one deal yes how quickly the second
one comes at the same landlord or
different uh so it was same landlord but
the brother
so he was like oh my brother's because
he was so impressed because you know
there was cobwebs everywhere the house
had been vacant for six months so lana
was actually losing money you know and
in either what two carpets down so that
also added to my negotiation of why the
price should i said i'll put the carpet
so you don't need to worry about that
i'll take care of that you know
yeah
adding value but you only paid 250
pounds for the carpet yeah but then
you're now getting a discounted rent
every month yeah and i was like listen
anything like 200 pounds i'll cover and
then i said new boiler when i sourced it
out where it's a landlord best you can
get five-year guarantee certificate as
well on the boiler a grand m50 including
labour tell me if you can get bill and
ladder was like mate
like literally gave me a round of
applause so is that my brother's got
this and literally gone there so that
landlord ain't going anywhere yeah lana
was like listen i've got my brother and
yeah the other cousin's coming soon and
i'm like and also for them i don't know
what their situation is but if they're
really busy if the property's been set
empty for six months if they're busy
they've got businesses they don't care
about a grand here or ground there like
but but but for you starting out in
property trying to build your business
that's financial freedom yes because if
you've got how much are you making off
those two properties
i'm making two thousand
five hundred and seventy pound per month
after two bang bro and you got those two
within five days yeah
and you find that how did you finance
them with two deals that you sold yeah
talk to me about that that's incredible
that literally is more impressive
than even when i when i do a financial
freedom challenge and i go out for a
week yeah you've done probably better
than i normally do
i mean i wouldn't say that
i wouldn't say that
yeah i mean i'm trying i'm trying
honestly i found so four deals you know
i called up dion i was like dion let's
come take a look at this property you
know oh you know it's a full bed but you
know it's just about to be fully you
know finished i said oh when the photo
is getting taken like oh you know
tonight at 8pm i said i'll be there i'm
not waiting for you to post it no i will
come with you while you're taking the
photos i'll have a look around and get
it done i'm not wait until next week i
need this deal today
you know assertive went there
agreed got everything sorted and
cool had that there now i need to raise
finance how am i going to do this i
listened to you because i've been to all
your events you talked about you know
raising finance and i literally had two
deals what did i do do source it sold it
3k 3k raise the finance
able to put down the months rent and a
deposit and then i negotiate the start
date for the first of the month so then
i wouldn't have to pay
my rent till the first of the following
month yeah so that way it gave me i pay
myself first
then i get more money then i'll pay
everyone else and then
invest in some more samuel east training
oh man that's awesome and then now you
you you're now working up now next steps
to academy which is going to be amazing
yes academy is the next step and
you know
with that also a couple brs i want to
get that information yeah cause you've
done the rent to rent training hmos
service accommodation killing that
financially free now you're looking to
do bigger deals move up into development
and brr um which is which is going to
create wealth which is what you you've
now got the time back your freedom back
now it's like i want to believe
generational wealth you've got a massive
heart to help people yeah um
so what's the what's the like 12-month
plan there what are you doing
so
we're looking well next month really
i've got two
deals that are about to get finalized
for supporting living
yeah
just leave it there
and then you know shadowing commenting
some vr deals you know training with
yourself you know the academy you know
right before my birthday march as well
so i want you know i'm getting out there
i'm getting stuck in not messing around
you know and you know get a couple br
deals
go in and then towards the end of next
year looking to you know raise finance
get into development because development
is what i want long term but i don't
need to wait for five years to get into
development why do i no yeah you know
six twelve months yeah six twelve months
yeah what would you advise emmanuel
because you've done really well you know
and your your results are not typical
you know so they're not typical so
anyone watching this i wouldn't want
people to think that that's normal
because it's not that's normal for me
doing it like normally what you've done
that's your standard and i said i'm
trained by samuel leeds i need to
achieve you know and i'm already a high
achiever in terms of a flakes what i'm
going to ask you though is like what do
you think what's going on up here what's
going on up here to to be able to make
you be able to push that hard and get
those those results so fast um you know
you've done you've obviously had a very
successful career in running until you
had your injuries unfortunately
what what makes a winner you know what
what what's the difference in mentality
because i think that property is 50
scale 50 technical to 50
but then it's also 50 up here
the person so talk to me about that
so for me the most important thing that
i've realized is the psychology is the
mental side a lot of people say they
want to do it but are you getting up to
do it are you doing are you getting the
skills are you applying it you know
people like yeah i made 10 phone calls i
was like great i made 70. you know uh
you know i went to two estate agents
okay i went to 40. you know it's the
it's the action and for me it's wanting
to just help people was to better myself
and also be free you know like i
remember i listened to you saying
you know like
with your property you know you like the
house that you live in you know and then
i think you know lana wanted to sell it
and you said no i'm taking it because
you know and i want to have that freedom
to be like no i like this house i like
the way that microwave plays music and
you know those things and those
you know i want to go on holiday and not
be like oh i've only got you know 500
pounds to spend no i'm going to go on
holiday be like
i want to go and i want to get massages
every day you know it's about living
life you know and at the same time i
want to give back and help people
because
i've got you know a passion for that you
know and it's something i like to do
anyway you know
retire my mom you know so she doesn't
have to keep working you know work until
your 70 you know things like that just
just create a better life for everyone
around me as well you're you're you're a
dude you know you just live in abundance
and and even though you're just sort of
starting out in property i can see that
you're going to be extremely successful
because i always say big energy equals
big bank yeah you know and you've got a
big energy your work ethic is second to
none um what what what what happened
over those four days that was so magical
because how old are you i'm 28. so
you're 28 years old so you know you've
been doing your thing you've been doing
your running which is great
then wanting to get into property you
come to the crash course you start
studying start watching me on youtube
but then over those four days suddenly
bang you become financially free in five
days what happened over those four days
emotions were
very calm and i think the craziest bit
was
i said okay
got this deal got this it was for me it
was finding the solutions i wasn't
stressing oh i haven't got the money oh
i haven't got the money it was like how
do i make this work okay i need to do
this i've got two here secure this
negotiate the rent down then i can
source it for a higher fee
cool got the money got to cap it all got
that sent over
bang deposit this that got everything
done
added a bit of work went into the local
store like you would say you know i went
to the big guys 1200 for carpet grand
for laminated flooring i said what nah
you know samuel said you know speak to
your local go down to your local shop
gone down to my local shop negotiated
250 pound plus a you know trust pilot
review and they loved it you know shook
my hand got it done the same day and you
know carpet cleans and then they even
helped me clean out the back gardens as
well and pain as well and i was like wow
i hope you left from a good review
brother oh i did i left them a good you
know two paragraphs so nah definitely so
those four days were literally came in
the energy you know the atmosphere at
your events is is amazing like you know
if you come to the training
like the networking is crazy as well you
know so many people with just the hunger
to succeed you know who did you sell
those deals to where did you find them
so i literally posted them on facebook
and also networking so i knew people you
know at your event at your training who
you know there were deal sources and
i had already you know like i said i
came to your dual selling masterclass
came to your development so i was
meeting all these different people some
people in the academy some people you
know they should just network network
network i would stay to the very end of
your events as well just to network make
sure i speak to as many people you know
putting in the time and effort and
literally oh yeah i'm gonna do so i'm
like oh okay could you show me how you
you would package it you know this and
literally sent me templates done it gray
out there and literally that's how i was
able to you know source it i think it's
also it's so important it's not just
what you know it's who you know so
you've learned the exact step by step
time this is samuel your network is your
net worth honestly i've heard you say
that so many times and literally i've
gone there know nothing about property i
have no contacts all i know is i'm here
to see samuel leeds you know and now
i've got i mean so many group chats you
know people message me constantly on
instagram i'm always helping them say
why don't you try this way or speak to
this person or or if i'm i don't know
i'll pass them to someone who i know
knows you know
second property that you got of the
brother is that hmo as well yeah hmo
license as well yeah started this year
as well in november as well so two rents
are two rental hmos now you're doing
supported living yes um and which is
making two and a half thousand pounds a
month in passive income yeah because
you've systemized it where you've got
yeah which is just crazy yeah honestly
and literally i've got people even
calling me ah you know i'll manage it
for you i'm like i've got this you know
i've got this you know because i've been
there i've done the work you know i was
in the refurb before like a br the only
thing is i didn't buy the property you
know i was praying in a new boiler it
was dormant for six months so i had to
you know get the gas on heating on
electricity on get everything turned on
deep clean you know and i've got
everything done in four days carpet
literally everything done what would be
best advice to someone starting out
wanting to emulate what you've done
the best advice i would say is
application you know and you've got to
believe you know because
if i didn't believe i wouldn't have the
effort you know i need you need to it's
all about understanding if you
understand what you want then you need
to find a solution to achieve it you
know and that's what i've done as okay i
need to find who can i find about
property simulates cool best in the
business let's go attended all the
events got the training and applied
myself not just one call two calls 30
calls 50 calls it's not enough you know
volume volume you have to keep going
keep you know rejection rejection until
you get there interesting what you say
about belief though because
i feel like if you didn't believe it was
possible when you got to that 30th 40th
50th
cool
you just psyched yourself out the game
yes but because you knew it was gonna
happen it's just a matter of time
you just had that belief it kept you
going yeah i said okay cool next call
let's go yeah and i feel like as well
what you believe you probably heard me
says before but what you believe you
will find the evidence to back up what
you already believe so if you believe oh
rent rent's hard oh i can't do it i'm a
loser you need money to do this you'll
then find the evidence you'll do a rent
to rent and then the landlord will go
right i need a deposit and you'll go i
knew i couldn't do this because i've got
the money i knew you needed money
where's everything actually no i don't
need my money i can be creative i can
finance i can sell a deal i can you you
you're you're what you believe you'll
almost manifest it into into reality and
as a runner and as an athlete and now a
businessman and a property entrepreneur
um it's great to talk about belief
because i agree i think belief is so
important and that's when people say to
me you know oh it's not possible you
make it sound too easy if it sounds too
good to be true it probably is i'm
thinking you guys you guys but you guys
the people that say that they're not
doing themselves any favors because by
saying oh it's it's hard oh and the
coming of excuses they're actually
robbing themselves the gift of financial
freedom yeah honestly they are and it's
you can't have that mindset
you have to believe you have to achieve
it and for me it's just it's just about
going and getting a solution how'd you
how did you get into like running and
stuff then so i started when i was
younger it was just for fun really i
just went for fun and then i just
started training time started you know
dropping down and then you know you get
a little notification are you going back
to this event
break a few records you know
went for a team gb and then i got
injured so i missed on the european
championship and then the fire and burn
to just come back the next year and make
the world championship team being the
top four in the country you know go
barcelona for the world championships
and you know it was
it's just about belief you know because
we've been a runner that it's a question
did you just suddenly realize one day
wow i'm a really good runner i'm awesome
and it just happened or did you have to
sort of say i'm gonna put the work in to
become a champion literally i was coming
last every race i like when i first i
was doing it for fun and then i was
coming last and i literally turned
around i said after today i'm gonna put
in that work and i'm going to win that
gold medal next year right so same story
belief yes hard work persistence
dedication yes definitely and the
discipline is on the mentality just keep
going you know and then i went back and
then i won the nationals you know
in 2011 and i went back the next day
because i doubled up at two events and
then i got bronze medal as well so the
fact that you know physically and
mentally you can go back and perform two
days back to back you know and achieve
you know two medals you know gold on a
bronze it just shows your character yeah
you know and you just gotta just
just i'm not accepting those you know
i'm here to win i never achieve i'm
ambitious and getting injured and sort
of because if you dedicate your whole
life to athletics and running and be and
then just get an injury
and then literally go from that uh you
say homeless at one point yeah i was
homeless people didn't even know i would
i was walking to train i was walking
hour hour and a half to training people
didn't even know you know because i was
like okay i've only got like 10
hostels the council put me in shelters
different nights different things i had
like couple suitcases did i mean i was
just dragging around people don't even
know this you know and people be like oh
i didn't know that but you see me i'll
be smiling you know there's so much but
i just kept going i said
things will change you know does that
believe when did you realize when you
when you're like homeless when did you
realize that financially you needed to
do something different when did you
realize that you know what i'm injured
that i need i need to find a new path i
want to be a proper entrepreneur when
did that happen
it happened last year you know last year
i sustained now the best shape of my
life i think it's gonna be my break out
here i'm gonna run nine seconds in a
hundred and literally got a big injury
and i was bed-bound for three months i
couldn't
move i couldn't walk couldn't get up to
go toilet it would take me about an hour
just to get out of bed to crawl to the
toilet you know so i was down and then i
was like mate i can't even do anything
right now i was like
i need to change this situation has to
change you know
and i i also know i can't run forever
what am i going to do after i stop
running you know so these thoughts start
coming you know when you're in bed and
you can't move you can't do anything you
know so i've gone from you know that to
like i said learning how to walk again
and things like that so i thought i need
to change this yeah so when did you when
property how did that come about you
know typing it in google having
instagram searching and then some guy
called similes came up i was like oh
it's another scammer
that's another one you know
yeah i was like oh he's this i was like
who's this salad i was like nah get out
of here
that's really so first impressions was
just like as i said number one you know
you know we have all these ads coming up
but in the second time so what's that
all right guys i'm doing a free event
this weekend i said free what am i doing
this week i said listen i'm going to be
sitting at home doing nothing let me
attend this event and let's see what
simulates is about so teddy video event
it's a free event was a free event okay
not got much money you know go to the
checkout one pound i was like one pound
[Laughter]
i know i know i know all right that's
alright fair enough it's a booking fee
so turning your event and i loved it you
know i got the inspiration your energy i
sat right at the front yeah i always say
right in front of all your events you
know right there learning notes ready
pumped and literally just taking it in
and i said okay whatever events training
does simon will have and i went to every
single one of them and then i agreed
okay rent right let's go you know after
i went to all of them development cash
flow and then castro right now let's be
financially free now before the end of
this year that was the goal and a
message i remember i messaged you 21st i
said when is wednesday let's go be
financially free before the 1st of
december yeah
so what's the difference between because
you've obviously been to a lot of the
free events yeah you've also done some
of the advanced training yeah both were
amazing
you know it's not like the free events
is like really rubbish with just a big
upsell the free events are amazing in
their own right give so much value for
that honestly yeah but then the advanced
training is more like
for people that actually really want to
do it we do it together we make the
calls together um it's a little bit more
um you know you've got more serious
people you've got mentorship um so what
was the difference between the free
training and the advanced training video
the free training was brilliant allowed
me to actually network a lot you know
and speak to people who already on the
academy understand oh how did you do it
you know ask those questions you know
because you've never been in property
free training is the best way to go you
know you've got people there who are
successful you know trained by yourself
i mean you can't ask for much more you
know and then the live
you know training you know that you've
paid for it's just
i can't even explain it's like times ten
times like it's ridiculous you know the
the amount of
value you get from the training is so
worth it like i was like mate i got it
for like one
people think it's expensive like oh two
thousand pounds just for you know a few
days training but it's like well
actually when you look at the people
you're gonna meet yeah the support the
it's almost like a franchise because
like immediately yeah you know firstly
made that back and then
long term it's you know it's i'm i've
kind of what time 10 times 20 that you
know so it's an investment you're
investing in yourself you know you want
to be successful or do you not and
that's how i saw it you know is it a
black or white like and i just felt like
i need to be successful and i came in
with the determination yeah you came and
known you were going to do it and i
think that's another thing like i can't
make anybody successful and i even say
this when when people involved advanced
training i say look there's no guarantee
that you're going to become financially
free but if you just do what i say yeah
and and
it's a process not a promise
you know it's an opportunity not a
guarantee but if you follow the process
you will get there honestly yeah and
that's literally what i've done like i
said i followed you know your
negotiation skills and i made it my own
i was like okay this is what sami will
do but there's only one samuel leads
there's only one emmanuel stevens you
know so i took it adapted to adapted it
to my style and then i've gone out there
and i've done it my way you know and
that's the best thing you know is
someone who can show you exactly how to
do it i mean your online training as
well don't forget that that's brilliant
i mean i learned so much from i went
through that four times you know before
even attending the the training that you
know paid for as well and we don't at
the live training we don't let people
off if if i'm like right find a deal
call the agents call the numbers yeah
you can't not do it yeah i'm like i'm
like hey you haven't coordinated let's
you ain't leaving the room until you've
done it so you're kind of forced to it's
like it's almost like you're you're
you're pushed in the same way that a
coach if you're being trained as an
athlete he's going to push you to do it
your agent of success is just showing up
because you show up in the right place
at the right time bang you know it's
gonna you're gonna get pushed to that
next level
um so you know it's been a real pleasure
working with you as well man thank you
samuel man honestly thank you for the
information the knowledge you know
financially free and i just i can't
thank you enough you know thank you for
your team as well they were great on the
day you know i know you had a lot of
people around you you know
evan's there helping me you know shout
out to evans as well so yeah awesome big
success and i'm sure we'll do a part two
interview maybe next year when you're
like a billionaire
listen it's there you know channel you
know build that generation of wealth
leave a legacy help charity
have my own charity you know like you do
as well you know it's very i could
relate so much to you and your energy i
was like yeah sam is the guy i can i can
believe in this respect man thanks so
much
guys i hope you found that inspirational
you heard it here first from from a
champion sprinter now applied that
winning mindset to property this is a
lot about mindset get around the right
people folks if you want to come and
join me at a training program guess what
i'm going to give you a free ticket
right now with a one pound booking fee
on the house
link in description one pound come and
spend the day with me the team so that
you can do the same thing too check out
in the description also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel that'd be
amazing hit like and i'll see you next
time